[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette suite
l'hebdo le retour sur l'actualité de la
semaine dans les yvelines
voici les titres de ce vendredi 2
octobre le président de la république
étaient présents dans les yvelines ce
vendredi s'est exprimé sur le projet de
loi sur les séparatismes tour d'horizon
des réactions des élus du département
la débuter la république en marge de la
6ème circonscription
natalia pouzy rêve sera également avec
nous ferons la parle ici berwick dans
l'actualité également vient de refermer
à la maison de la chimie
enjeu essentiel de cette deuxième
édition la formation dans le domaine de
la cybersécurité start-up grandes
entreprises encore ou encore pardon
collectivités des yvelines était
présente
et puis déplacement d'olivier véran à la
caf des yvelines ou encore assises du
numérique depuis montigny le bretonneux
nous reviendrons sur ce qui a fait
l'actualité cette semaine
[Musique]
ce à quoi nous devons nous attaquer
c'est le séparatisme islamistes
c'est l actualité du jour le président
de la république était aux mureaux dans
les yvelines pour prononcer un discours
sur le futur projet de loi sur les
séparatismes qui sera d'ailleurs
présenté le 9 décembre prochain pour
revenir sur ce discours natalia pouzy
rêve bonsoir vous êtes des mutins la
république en marche de la 6ème
circonscription des yvelines
première question alors un accusé un
type emmanuel macron d'être trop prudent
de ne pas prononcer les mots islam
radical ou encore islamisme on viens de
l'entendre aujourd'hui c'est fait qu'en
pensez vous mia je crois que le
président a réussi un exercice assez
difficile lisnard sert sans faire
d'amalgamé s'envoie stigmatiser les
individus note aiguë mais en ciblant
très clairement très nettement la
question les problèmes posés par
l'islamisme donc cette version politique
des voix les principes républicains
l'islamisme radical et outre la cime
antique du camp même du discours du
président il a annoncé cinq piliers
c'était vraiment les cinq mesures phares
sur la sur le futur projet de loi sur le
séparatisme l'une des mesures qui fait
beaucoup réagir c'est celle sur l'école
on écoute justement la déclaration du
président de la république à ce sujet
dès la rentrée 2021 l'instruction à
l'école sera rendue obligatoire pour
tous dès 3 ans l'instruction à domicile
sera strictement limitée notamment aux
impératifs de santé
donc on l'a bien compris le président
l'a déclaré plus du tout d'école à la
maison à partir de 3 ans sauf impératif
de santé
quel impact pensez vous que ça va avoir
justement sur les cinquante mille ans
font scolarisés à domicile selon les
chiffres du président et leurs parents
et également tous ne sont pas évidemment
dans une forme de séparatisme islamistes
il vient il a si je souligne le d
loppement des dix polarisation
kiabi d'un phénomène qui est en place et
qui conduisent des enfants ils y soient
retirés de l'école parce que ils ne vont
pas participer aux activités de sportive
à la piscine à côté activité sous
prétexte fallacieux et qui mènent leur
retraite l'école ou être placés dans des
structures soient familiales ce pas
complètement en dehors du système et en
dehors de tout contrôle
or l'école se doit de zeeuw et qui
prépare nos futurs citoyens
donc il est dans ses enfants soient
comme il l'a dit exposé à l'altérité
qu'ils soient dans un environnement leur
libre choix et la liberté de devenir et
futurs citoyens de la nation
donc pour vous ça ne va pas pénaliser
justement des enfants qui étaient
scolarisés à la maison et qui ne faisait
pas partie
forcément de cet islam radical de ce
séparatisme de ce communautarisme et
bien je crois qu'il faut être
pragmatique il y aura toujours des
exceptions ou par votre dérogation il en
a déjà annoncé une concerne les enfants
sont peut-être le malade qui ont besoin
de rester chez eux et je pense que dans
d'autres circonstances
et c'est lorsque le projet de loi sera
examiné à l'assemblée que nous pourrons
décider d'amender ou pas voici nous en
faisons entrer dans cette catégorie
d'autres des dérogations pour et les
métiers d'une école ou bien c'est pour
ça que les enrichit et pourra répondre à
ces interrogations
et justement est-ce que vous avez déjà
vous en tant que député des idées
d'amendements alors moi j'ai une idée
d'amendements qui concerne effectivement
l'enseignement qui serait puisque il a
été un an des cours de langue arabe
on le perd vite et longues et si c'est
des endroits où il peut y avoir en main
un mélange avec 10 et les sortes
d'obstacles
je suis également favorable
l'ampli yopougon mais jo soit ne
consacrer en 6e ou 5e explique soit plus
à un enseignement historique que mon
équipe ne répond pas et de toutes les
risques religion dans une équipe hybride
est complètement oui je du coup une
autre mesure c'est l'obligation de
neutralité pour pour changer de sujet
déjà applicable donc aux agents du
service public
emmanuel macron a annoncé qu'il allait
l'étendre au délégataire de service
public donc ça concerne les entreprises
privées évidemment le parisien à ce
sujet revient aujourd'hui même sur la
radicalisation de michael harpon ce
policier qu'il ya un an avait assassiné
quatre de ses collègues à la préfecture
de police de paris
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france pour rappel a même
déclaré sur rmc que le véritable danger
était moins le séparatisme que
l'entrisme ce phénomène donc la présence
d'islamistes radicaux dans la fonction
publique
pensez vous que cette mesure sera
efficace contre ce phénomène nous dire
quelles mesures fortes et pline un btan
aux entreprises mais des galères et
dangereuse escalade en mesure principale
est nette
le vois bien du droit colonial eu un
doute ou que service public on va plaire
gérard larcher nouvellement réélu au
sénat était invité ce matin sur le
plateau de france info il y a déclaré
ceci c'est un sujet que le président a
repoussés depuis maintenant plus de deux
ans et demi et le sujet essentiel c'est
sujet de la laïcité dans la république
vous savez pour moi le fondement c'est
la loi de 1905
le principe c'est aristide briand qui
nous rappelle la loi doit protéger la
foi tant que la fois n'entend pas dicter
la loi
tout est dit et à partir de cela on peut
décliner décliner j'allais dire ce qui
doit être au coeur des valeurs de la
république et donc refusé tout ce qui
sépare tout ce qui fragmentent la
république et la communauté nationale
le président lui l'a dit dans son
discours le problème ce n'est pas la
laïcité je cite il a déclaré même qu'il
fallait des l'islam dans notre pays à se
structurer et il a annoncé parmi ces
cinq mesures que les imams serait
désormais formés en france par le
conseil français du culte musulman
évidemment est plutôt qu'à l'étranger
est ce que cet engagement de l'état est
compatible avec la laïcité en france par
rentrer subir les vingt ans gère ce qui
n'a pas lieu d'être tant que mesure des
études ici car le temps on arrive à
monter en puissance pour former des
imams et ses enfants
je pense qu'ils ne me régaler et qui on
vient
cadre du renfort de bien eh bien merci
natalia pouzy rêve d'avoir été avec nous
sur ce plateau dans l'actualité
également la deuxième édition de la
paris cyber week se tenait à la maison
de la chimie mercredi 30 septembre et
jeudi 1er octobre
au programme des rencontres et des
échanges entre les différents acteurs du
domaine de la cyber sécurité des start
up des grands groupes mais aussi
organismes et collectivités publiques
avec un enjeu majeur la formation sur ce
secteur un reportage de nicolas landry
une invitée de marque pour le deuxième
jour de l'apparition berwick maria
gabriel commissaire européenne à
l'innovation et à la recherche
le numérique et la cyber sécurité un
enjeu majeur pour l'union européenne
avec notamment la question de la
formation
nous avons besoin d'experts aujourd'hui
il manque 300 mille experts en
cybersécurité c'est pour cela le rôle de
l'éducation le rôle des universités est
fondamentale nous avons besoin de nos
enseignants et enseignants qu'ils
puissent parler des métiers de la
cybersécurité qu'ils puissent avoir
accès à des formations des conférences
des échanges informels cette deuxième
édition permet de mettre en avant les
expériences de terrain
c'est le cas notamment du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
engagé dans la cybersécurité davantage
avec saint quentin en yvelines c'est que
lorsqu'on a une idée et qu'on veut
l'expérimenté souvent un très bon
accueil des équipes nous allons été
proactif à la fois avec l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pour développer des formations de niveau
master nous sommes aussi en lien avec
liste i avec l'école d'ingénieurs de
l'ue vs q parmi les acteurs dynamiques
sur ce territoire
roxy box et silicone sylla de société
guyancourt toise à l'initiative de la
création de l'association first la
création de cette entité a été annoncé
durant la paris games week elle regroupe
7 pm spécialiste de la cybersécurité
notre ambition est de
travailler ensemble afin de faire
émerger un écosystème de pouvoir
permettre d'adresser efficacement le
marché est donc de permettre une
amélioration globale de la du niveau de
sécurité des tpe pme et surtout
accompagner les tpe et les pme dans leur
trajectoire d'innovation autour des
métiers de la cybersécurité d'après nos
informations saint-quentin-en-yvelines
serait en contact avec les collèges du
territoire et l'éducation nationale pour
orienter les stagiaires de troisième
vers les entreprises spécialistes du
numérique et en cyber sécurité
revenons maintenant sur ce qui a fait
l'actualité cette semaine
[Musique]
deux ministres olivier ferrand et adrian
attaque et se sont rendus à la caf des
yvelines de versailles mercredi 30
septembre pour présenter un dispositif
pour éviter les impayés des pensions
alimentaires et prévenir la précarité
lancé jeudi 1er octobre
140 millions d'euros ils seront alloués
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
et de nicolas landry deux ministres à la
caf de versailles ce mercredi 30
septembre olivier véran ministre des
solidarités de la santé le secrétaire
d'état adrien taquet chargée de
l'enfance et des familles sont venues
présenter la première phase du service
public sur les pensions alimentaires
objectifs du dispositif éviter les
impayés prévenir la précarité des
familles d'abord elle est capable de
vous verser une allocation d'environ 116
euros par mois pour vous permettre déjà
de tenir en attendant que ce service
public est prélevée directement sur les
ressources du conjoint qui n'a pas
verser la pension alimentaire
ce qu'il vous doit de manière à vous le
verset y compris d'ailleurs en regardant
jusqu'à deux ans en arrière
ainsi il n'y aura plus demain de pension
alimentaire non versée
ce dispositif lancé ce 1er octobre est
attendue par des dizaines des familles
yvelinois c'est le cas pour jolie fille
serio lee mère de quatre enfants
originaire de montigny le bretonneux
séparés depuis quatre ans ça facilite
énormément de choses énormément démarche
parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident
malgré les procédures judiciaires malgré
est repassé devant la justice pour
fixez des pensions alimentaires dans les
yvelines on recense plus de trente neuf
mille familles monoparentales
actuellement 850 de procédure de
recouvrement pour impayés de pension
alimentaire sont ouvertes mercredi 30
septembre la ville de montigny le
bretonneux organisé le premier forum
sans solution à la rentrée un événement
en partenariat avec yveline information
jeunesse
au programme rencontres avec des
professionnels offre de contrat et de
formation reportage de justin brasil
accompagner les jeunes sans projet c'est
ce que propose le forum sans solution à
la rentrée un événement organisé à
montigny le bretonneux
il permet aux jeunes de rencontrer des
professionnels de la formation et de
l'emploi
l'objectif de ce forum il est de pouvoir
faire bénéficier les jeunes du bassin
saint quentin
et versailles de d'offres d'emploi
d'offres de contrats d'apprentissage de
formation et
qu'ils puissent effectivement
moment donné s'orienter et
et qu'on puisse leur donner voilà des
outils est aussi vraiment des offres
d'emploi pour pouvoir avancer
suite à cette crise qui a été vraiment
très très très très dur quarante deux
exposants étaient présents sur place
pour l'occasion
objectif proposer aux jeunes service
civique emploi ou encore formation
remplir nos classes qui ne sont pas
pleines voilà pour
à la fois nous ça nous permet de les
remplir et puis ça permet de trouver des
solutions pour les jeunes qui n'en n'ont
pas et qui cherche encore des places
dans ces formations là ils peuvent se
renseigner prendre contact et puis
s'inscrire 200 jeunes entre 15 et 20 ans
étaient attendus ils sont venus pour
candidater ou encore se renseigner pour
leurs projets je cherche un emploi ou un
stage en librairie et j'espère grâce aux
organismes comme pôle emploi ce cahier
emploi et la mission locale vous fut
déjà inscrits pourront peut-être m'aider
en tout cas à trouver un travail ou en
stage je me suis essentiellement
renseigner auprès de ces organismes et à
plusieurs et plein de gens accessibles
qui sont là pour répondre à toutes nos
questions notamment bank sky emploi
si j'ai bien compris qui est prêt qu'il
ya plein de choses à proposer donc avoir
pour les recontacter et s'inscrire sur
leur sur leur site un autre forum sera
organisé le mercredi 7 octobre
il se déroulera à la maison des
associations d'aubergenville mardi 29
septembre vous parlions des enjeux liés
au numérique qui ont explosé ces
dernières années
le numérique est partout omniprésent
dans nos vies il nécessite néanmoins des
interrogations
les assises du numérique qui avait lieu
mardi à montigny le bretonneux ont
permis de réfléchir et d'aider les élus
à s'emparer de ce sujet les précisions
d'astrid bergère comment réussir la
transformation digitale de nos
territoires c'était tout l'objet des
troisièmes assises du numérique
parmi les thèmes abordés lissante et la
sûreté urbaine la dématérialisation ou
encore le numérique pour l'éducation et
cette année ces sujets ont une résonance
particulière pendant évidemment la crise
sanitaire elle confinement qu'on a
connus on a vu que le numérique prenez
vraiment une place prépondérante dans la
vie des citoyens
la première table ronde était consacrée
au numérique pour l'éducation
raccordement à la fibre très haut débit
ou achat de vidéoprojecteurs interactifs
les établissements opère un tournant et
depuis 2000 15 18 collèges des yvelines
participent à un projet pilote grâce
auquel dix mille élèves et 1000
professeurs ont reçu des tablettes un
des souhaits était de
travailler le passage du manuel scolaire
papier traditionnel un ensemble de
ressources numériques dont les manuels
scolaires numériques pourquoi pas cette
table ronde était donc l'occasion entre
autres de faire le bilan de ce projet
pilote qui s'achève cette année pour les
élèves la joute d'appareils numériques
comme la tablette en plus des outils
papier semble bénéfique
là tu as peut-être leur sert pour
le recours la tablette leur sert moment
des examens aussi puisque nous avons
intégré dans l'oral de soutenance du
brevet des collèges le fait qu'il poids
en mesure de montrer un usage pertinent
de leurs outils numériques et cela va
aussi développer des ambitions
personnelles chez les élèves
le bilan est d'autant plus positif pour
cet établissement qu'élèves et
professeurs ou utiliser la tablette
pendant tout le confinement ça nous a
permis de garder du lien véritablement
avec nos élèves et de continuer un
travail de qualité sap a juste été un
pis-aller
moi je dis souvent aux mains amusant
mais comme on n'avait pas les scories du
quotidien eh ben pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans j'ai terminé mon programme
en troisième en lettres au total plus de
400 personnes ont participé à ces
troisièmes assises du numérique
pour la quatrième année le salon de
l'innovation it onomie se tenait aux
mureaux du 30 septembre au jeudi 1er
octobre les entreprises exposantes avait
tout pour but de mettre le numérique au
service de l'autonomie des personnes
dépendantes
un reportage de patrick jacques de
dixmude et de bixente mais rien senti
steban organisé par la plateforme
départementale hinvi le salon hit onomie
a pour but de proposer des solutions
tourner vers l'avenir pour les seniors
ou les personnes en situation de
handicap
des conférences ainsi que de nombreux
stands étaient proposés durant les deux
jours de l'événement
on a créé le hub autonomie qui a pour
ambition développer un incubateur un
accélérateur de projets
notamment
d'organiser le territoire
d'expérimentation et le département des
yvelines est le département des
hauts-de-seine qui sont les principaux
soutiens
il était important de travailler sur des
leviers pour améliorer les conditions de
travail des professionnels parmi les
exposants présents de nombreuses
entreprises yvelinoise qui cherche à
collaborer afin d' améliorer et
diversifier leurs services l'idée là
c'est de faire un appartement immersif
on va pouvoir voir les différentes
technologies qui peuvent être adaptées
au logement
alors il ya bien sûr notre télé
assistance de jarvis access mais vous
voyez il ya tout un tas d'autres
produits ici de la vaisselle spécifique
pour les personnes
comment dire atteinte de parkinson on a
des tables qui peuvent s'ajuster en
termes de hauteur de but étant de
rapprocher cette technologie de les
mettre à disposition les patients et à
la disposition du corps médical afin que
lui-même puisse prolonger sa
bienveillance sur le patient des fois
même en dehors de l'hôpital ou de la
clinique au vert au public lors des
éditions précédentes
l'économie était cette année réservé aux
professionnels la crise sanitaire a
d'ailleurs impact et certaines demandes
on a aussi la demande des fois
départementale d'avoir des technologies
qui s'intègrent beaucoup plus dans
l'habitation du patient lui-même afin
d'avoir une interaction à la fois avec
le monde médical l'accompagnent ont bien
sûr où la famille un salon virtuel a
aussi été mise en place pour pouvoir
assister aux stands et aux conférences à
distance
en cette période d'épidémie jeudi nous
sommes partis à la découverte du brame
du cerf depuis mi août et jusqu'à mi
octobre c'est le moment propice pour
aller l'entendre le parc animalier
forestier l'espace rambouillet située à
son chant est l'endroit idéal pour
découvrir ce son particulier immersion
voici le brame le cri caractéristiques
du cerf entre la mi août et la mi
octobre
c'est la période de reproduction du roi
de la forêt pour impressionner les
biches et de façon à repousser les
autres mâles lecerf pousse son brame
pour pouvoir transmettre ces gemmes à
l'espace rambouillet où la grande faune
forestière gambade dans les 180 hectares
de forêt faire entendre ce phénomène
naturel aux visiteurs est un moyen de
faire de la pédagogie tout le plaisir
que des gens vont prendre ici on espère
que c'est du plaisir qu'ils vont à
prayssas répercuter sur tous les milieux
naturels qu'ils iront voir après ça va d
inciter à sortir à venir dans les forêts
et à venir dans avec beaucoup de respect
en fait par rapport au milieu naturel
pour répondre à cet objectif le parc
animalier et forestier géré par l'office
national des forêts organise d'ailleurs
des animations dont le matin ou assez
tard le soir pendant toute la période du
brame un guide accompagne les curieux
pour aller au plus près des animaux mais
le parc est aussi ouvert toute la
journée pour qui souhaiterait partir en
quête de ce son si particulier
l'idée c'est de prendre l'air voilà
moi je ne connaissais pas l'espace
rambouillet donc ça me permet aussi de
découvrir
et puis parce que la période des brames
dessert donc c'est vraiment voilà mais
on y venait pour sa ba un peu tous les
animaux les sangliers et j'en ai déjà vu
ba des débuts et pourquoi pas des tiers
les visiteurs qui auront eu la chance ou
non d'entendre le brame pourront dans
tous les cas venir à l'espace
rambouillet observer les naissances
issues de cette période de reproduction
les petits faons devrait naître en mai
ou juin prochain et pour terminer cet
hebdo la nuit blanche revient à la
commanderie ce samedi 3 octobre de 20h à
minuit
de nombreux rendez vous sont prévus pour
l'occasion et parmi les propositions
artistiques
la compagnie le grand jeu t elle donnera
deux représentations de son spectacle
réplique dans la cour de la commanderie
à 21h et 22h30
nous reviendrons sur cet événement
culturel incontournable dans le 7-8
journal de lundi
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 l'hebdo
on se retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau résumé de l'actualité de la
semaine dans les yvelines
d'ici là l'information revient lundi à
18h dans le 7-8 journal présenté par
grégory canal et vous pourrez en voir
cette émission et toutes les autres sur
notre site internet tv 78 points com ou
sur notre application mobile tv 78
jusqu'ici je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end et une très bonne soirée
[Musique]